[Music]
because it's Christmas now can use
whatever keywords I want alright so
today we're going to go through some of
our favorite hacks lessons fails from
2019 to a year in review so I dropped
that school which we came here doctor
otherwise it's been probably the hardest
year of my life but the main thing that
didn't go well was I started the year
snapping my hamstring underneath 255
kilos as you're moving into the new year
if I could give you one piece of advice
what piece of advice would be go sober
second piece of advice would be sleep
with you thought outside of your room
but third piece of advice would be get
morning routine I spoke to someone this
week who said to me that they got dog
because I settled on masters Suzy we
should be careful
ladies and gentlemen welcome back a very
Merry Christmas from us here at modern
wisdom
Johnny noosa have joined me anyway it's
Christmas Merry Christmas
hope that you've had a fantastic year
we're going to be going through open
that now what do you do ladies and
gentlemen welcome back a very Merry
Christmas to you I'm joined by John
Yousef from propane fitness calm welcome
back to us welcome back indeed as he's
actually take two because we were being
big no of you they're being Christmas
elves um as you can see Johnnie's
wearing a familiar jumper except for the
fact it's broken you've got an indicate
that I don't think it's broken fully
better some would say better better
anyway rising if you are only listening
I'd suggest you head to YouTube to check
out our Christmas jumpers and all of
this black noise it's lovely
really nice nice oh she's far too small
for him you can't really see that that's
that's your girlfriend's jumper I think
so take it slow in the snow and it's a
sloth with ear muffs I like a cautionary
notice isn't it yeah it is
you can stop by the side of the road
just waiting take that step very
sensible
yeah so today we're going to go through
some of our favorite hacks lessons fails
from 2019 to a year in review what it is
that we've been getting up to
Johnny hot lava coal for Christmas lump
of coal there you go what would you like
to know well what have you okay here's
one what have you dropped within the
last year in terms of sort of routine or
products consistence that's a great
question that is a surprise team ROM wad
many B's utility and how do you feel
having so no different I would say why
he drops promises a Chris went to see
mr. McGill came back and was like don't
do wrong with Johnny otherwise you'll
snap yourself
so I think I probably didn't because I
was doing it it was taking a long time I
was still getting injured and I was
still feeling tight and I was still
feeling you know pain discomfort like as
you would normally expect from training
so try dropping it also notice not no
change really so I do miss it but not
for the right reasons well yeah no I
agree I agree completely so my my
reasons
ramaa die still think is a fantastically
useful tool and it's a beautiful way to
start your morning there's just certain
physiologies mind being one of them the
changes that the stretch is elicits it
doesn't agree with so Ron Watts got
Yusuf what you added or taken away this
year that's been surprising cuz you do
like water down Ron will do it you're
like old gymnastic stuff yeah cause it's
gnostics the sport of Ron what it's
competitive ramen
they don't have seated straddle they
have like other like proper names for
the things so I dropped that's cool
which we came became here doctor God so
and as far as habits like I think
there's quite a big shift with having to
go from like pressurizing yourself for a
certain point on assessment to just
doing the job so that's been quite a big
shift and I think quite a lot of
challenges with time management and just
juggling a lot more in terms of energy
time sleep that can be vented to you
after your life finally in the real
world after ten years of being west you
went in for a bit wrong went wrong bit
and they're not getting it yeah from
trading where there's just loads of
blood and poo isn't there quite a lot
how much body fluid do you see luckily
so we were saying this before that you
have kind of insulated from a little bit
whereas nurses
god bless they're on the front line they
just get taking fire like they get
punched
got punched last week by someone assumed
and the deal it's always like the first
port of call for like yes I'll [ __ ]
meself
[Laughter]
it's absolutely excusable you know
someone who can't help it but sometimes
you just get people who those are just a
bit lazy or a bit just vindictive and
like there's a can be a sense of I've
I've paid for this so I'm gonna who has
you sure you don't you know [ __ ]
yourself the business if you pay taxes
you our Hospital now this well the I
mean it's not common but you can what is
it what I can remember who the comedian
is who say so it's like how it's like
making a dirty protest against the
standards in a hotel by [ __ ] the bed
then realizing I mean you've got to wake
up in a [ __ ] bed yeah accept the fact
that someone comes and then shits the
bed for you in hospital don't make you
have to [ __ ] in the bed like as you
leave the bed they take they take the
pillow away to the pivot comes and then
it goes yeah so you've changed a lot to
do with that and I guess that you sleep
is gonna be a bit of a challenge and
stuff now as well I think I've learned a
lot about myself with doing night shifts
was he learned switching between so just
how much it affects how stupid you are
so in fact there we go the the big
lesson has been it has anyone seen the
Shane Parrish stupidity podcast yes it
talks about the seven factors of
stupidity which are being in a group
outside of your normal group being
outside of your domain of competence
being in the presence of an expert or
being an expert yourself being in a
crowd
having sensory overload or being tired I
think those are the seven almost like
and do you say at least six if so the
first couple of months you are just
you're like I'm so aware that I'm
operating on ten percent brain because
everything it just is designed to make
you stupid like and he defines stupid
not as a lack of intelligence but
missing what is conspicuously obvious
because of these factors and so slowly
as you begin to have mitigate those
use more of your brain you can think
more clearly but yeah very very
interesting experience because in
corporate world like the way that people
rationalize something of like don't
worry it's not that bad it's not life
and death you know that's the thing that
everyone says mm-hmm
and zeros like yeah are you trade in
life is that right she's reading it
whereas you are in the only scenario
really where it is only ever is life and
death and poo sometimes it's just before
who is is just on the spectrum isn't it
of life and death like will happen ah
specific points on the spectrum of life
and death what about you Chris hold on
you didn't ask them answer the question
I said what have you drop stop being
student all right okay dropped his
medical degrees there are there any
habits or routines that you sort of
voluntad like that wouldn't have
happened anyway that you stop doing so
things like Anki using right one of the
surrounding habits that you have around
that and I think it opens up a huge
amount of RAM in one sense because
you're not like trying to just stuff
your brain with as much like the people
who don't want to use it is space
repetition flashcard software that helps
medical students remember what they need
to learn yes show summary yeah very very
good bit of software actually it like
it's you create your a deck of flash
broth except if you're making 10,000
like me that helped me did you finish up
ten thousand so really if you are a
medical student or an any student and
you have Anki flash card deck with more
than 10,000 flash cards in it and you
send me a screenshot at Chris relax on
Instagram I will send you a case if not
go for free
Wow how am I gonna protect against
people fudging that it's a long process
to are you still jiggling
no but you will be pleased to know that
I unwrapped my six minute diarrhea I've
started reading through the preamble
which is it long yeah it is the big
buy-in I thought it would be up a couple
of pages no it's
yeah so I've not started the actual
journal process but will you intend on
maybe doing it for the new year
yeah Wow I did you know what it is I was
gonna ask for it back really why I was
gonna say I was just gonna so I'll just
give it to someone who's gonna use is
gonna actually appreciate it so hold on
why have you stopped journaling because
you used you don't want to know I as in
like I've never really journal as a
consistent thing I just do it as when
things come up and I type them up right
but I'm convinced now to try six player
diary
I think pen to paper and having a
physical like everything away and just
sit I think there's something to be said
for just doing a like I mean you're a
huge like you're the one that got be on
to it which is like doing a a long-form
brain dump that's just total lands off
mm-hmm rather than just like a partial
one cuz that's like having a partial poo
isn't it like you might
just relieve the pressure a little bit
but then all the good stuffs still there
yeah still inside
I'm man I'm I'm really really happy to
hear that you're gonna use it I'm
genuinely excited for the fact that it
you might not think it [ __ ] like when I
first saw it's just this like trendy
little mmm it's month so Dominic Spence
the guy that the German dude that's
written it you can see by the number of
that references that's in it and how
thorough the studies anyone who doesn't
know we're talking about six-minute
diary daily journaling three minutes and
morning three minutes and evening three
questions he asked I've just filled in
my fifth so that's like maybe a thousand
pages of writing maybe thousand days of
journaling and I thought how long if
you've had it for what the ideas I think
I'm getting more I keep on getting more
keep on getting more two years two years
of that consistent sorry two half years
of consistent use your so a consistent
with our stuff it's just my morning
routine mine just like my morning
routine is was it not six hours at one
point your morning routine there's a
point last year where you said like your
total morning routine was sick if I
wasn't for it full like dick and balls
and included I was including my training
time in that so like training plus
training time is like three and a half
because if it's six hours that's just
yeah but that's so this is what I've
been something I've been thinking about
recently I love the fact that a morning
routine is this hermetically sealed
petri dish for self development
unencumbered and unmolested by everyone
else everybody my first sentence I've
ever heard why just to say it what was
it a medically sealed - yep
of an income are you saying that I'm
just being Latin for boss for them for
no reason because it's Christmas I can
use whatever [ __ ] words I want all
right Chris this tastes caffeinated I
believe you sponsor we got a new sponsor
everybody
NACO shout out to knock oh thank you
Johnny's terrified to the fact that the
one that has in big capital letters
caffeine free sugar free carbonate
what's a bit alarming is if you just
glance at it you see 5,000 milligrams I
tasted them I was like because it's just
a PCA yeah I know I looked at it Mysore
fire it's okay you're totally correct
this is made in a factory which contains
may contain yeah I mean you were
terrified it would have nuts in me no
those are those are okay there's a card
company on them on the morning time
you're getting money routine it's no
one's getting any waiting to stop me
from doing your [ __ ] what I've realized
is if you become very very anal about
how you do your morning routine you can
work out exactly cisely how long
everything is gonna take here especially
when you're doing things that are quite
discreet so the state app takes 8
minutes
the meditation of the 20-minute session
takes 20 minutes reading takes 20
minutes of the countdown timer didn't
along the six-minute diary actually take
so I tend to take a little bit longer
it's the first thing I do so I'll be
drinking water probably settling into
wherever I'm sat I would say 5 minutes
of Hell so ok so it's not just like oh
that's in the morning I'm and then as
the evening but does it mean evening one
tends to be quick if it's supposed to be
three minutes in the morning visitor
evening yeah but I'm a bit worried that
you'll just as I've seen you should have
tried lots of different things and
typically you aren't brought in by like
Chris and I would read something or like
hear something or try something new and
be really kind of sold on it it's been
fun and nice I worry that you'll read
the preamble and just be like and then
you'll try it for a while and he'll be
like I tried to comfort I but yeah but
so I suppose like I was bought into it
or is it FOMO wanting to even miss the
fact that he was sufficiently concerned
about potential gains to open it and
read m60 whatever is 60 70 pages hits
the by unit a stone I think but anyway
so you you know exactly how long
everything's gonna take on your morning
right and this is as you moving into the
new year if I could give you one piece
of advice what piece of advice would be
go sober second piece of advice would be
sleep with your phone outside of your
room but third piece of advice would be
get morning routine and as you see this
is how long everything is going to take
blah blah blah um what you realize is if
I was able to run my day forward like
that if I was able to do 12 hours of
this at the same fidelity morning
routine mmm imagine how much you'd get
done every single essentially every
minute anyway if you could live your
life as if it was a morning routine
yeah just it and I find that what I mean
is like every minute is accounted for
and these and during that minute you're
doing precisely what you're supposed to
be doing so that's what I that's
something I try and do in my morning
routine it's that's a carnie poor thing
I've like try and plan out as much of
your days you possibly can on a bit of
paper or like in your journal or
whatever 15 minute blocks I do it 30
minute blocks so like you know how long
does it take to get there and how long
am I going to be doing on this task and
there's something that Carl says which
is like he's convinced that a 9:00 to
5:00 window perfectly planned or I
planned out in a minute that person gets
way more done than the 60-hour workweek
person he's just like yeah you know what
you so you can much more easily control
the intensity of your work then you
can't control the passage of time yeah I
mean you know we get to do we get to do
the second one so so yeah I guess for me
doubling down a morning routine probably
one of them has been focused on rest the
meditation technique
shins and Jung's five ways which is both
of our meditation coaches Braun's doing
to the people that don't know I'm
talking about it's just a particular
type of meditation focus you're focusing
on the absence of a visual auditory or
somatic experience in your head it
sounds a bit whew
but bottom line is I've now managed to
ingrain that and I did it for so long
they feels like getting a squeegee I'm
wiping out a window clean and if there's
something that arises it must be similar
to your releasing technique or it must
have a similar sort of effect I can
drill it Evert drill this so much now
that I can do see rest here us feel rest
and after that genuinely feels like my
mind's cleaner after that little thing
about good old a typically six - yeah
like getting one of those like wash your
brain
okay so their body that's what that's
one of them what else what have you
doing this year that you failed up
Johnny other than you just hurt your
wrist at CrossFit yeah so I've written
down on my on a notes document what went
well and what didn't go well the main
thing that didn't go well was I started
the year stopping my hamstring
underneath 255 kilos cuz it no IT band
it well everything it was like it was
something here okay I call it I refer to
it as Mohammed ring I don't think some
people thought was my sartorial that's
all real it's like must or it sounds
like you're a Roman guard and then
there's the phalanx so they call it
Sartorius because you know you say this
is a sartorial piece of work yeah it's a
tailor because the tailor's muscle
because it attaches no side see yeah so
it's basically as the inside it's that
way it's so it's what allows you to
bring your heel up and in right
which would make snow cheese in the
position that you're in started the
earth by lightening yourself snuff
yeah stop Powell if T the worst thing
that happened on that evening was so
that's just happened up in the garage
right so get the bottom and is like it
and I hear it over see you on the video
yeah
so dump that forward and then like limp
back into the house
don't even unload the t-55 still they
know Jeff took Dexter so like Dexter was
just the puppy at the time took him for
a walk and he slipped out of his harness
so well like on a roundabout okay big
roundabout and the back is picking up
his poo and he'll just like Boulud and
this other direction like slips out his
harness I'm like [ __ ] so I then had to
run like cuz I mean he's running the
wards that was there for this roundabout
and just just being adrenaline dump no
pain for a couple of seconds just went
full gas pedal after Dex that caught him
picked up and I was like oh my god and
then just this area was just like
red-hot Wow so try to recover through
that try to compete didn't compete was
like I've had it with powerlifting did
six months across fit and then hit my
wrist and you're now considering going
back and what I'm doing what I can so
like what I can't do is basically the
powerless it's like I can't even do a
chin-up condo you know that price bench
is iffy but that was just from catching
power clean on this side and missing it
on my right and then the bar just John
Doe unfortunate but so injuries I think
but like I just I mean that's always so
unwell this year what did you put down
is going well and so the flip side of
that was I experimented a lot in Fitness
than what the most I have done probably
since I was like sixty knots inside many
yeah so like did some 5k runs time down
did obviously six months of CrossFit did
oh I feel like a it's the probably the
most amount of time I've taken away from
barbell strength yeah place traditional
barbell works it seemed really good in
front what about looking forward what
did it so you've got those two things
which are like kind of two sides of the
same sort mmm what does that mean for
2020 I don't know I think and this
probably doesn't apply to everybody but
I think the thing that keeps pulling me
back to powerlifting
is I feel like I'm I feel like I have
unfinished business and pile of thing
like I really want a 700-pound that lift
that was my girl for so long
and what's that 3:23 17.5 okey so close
so I know what exactly so like it's so
annoying because of that it's it is what
is that joining in competition or just
in training so so this is two thing so
one I still hold the 93 kilos that live
record and there's a guy who's just
pulled 300 and training who's right on
the heels of it so I quite like to bump
it a little bit have to get back down to
the 93 how would my words these are
these are the decisions I think I'm so
key in fees gets 93 man
you would be yeah so I'm just thinking
about just getting really lean Jack and
just become whatever whatever make but
it's interesting cuz I don't have the
same like desire for anymore I don't
know why aesthetically yeah I just
fitness menopause man well yeah I think
like we've all been through the fitness
probably the past you may be through
your sales podcast started crispness
virgin cross cross yeah there there's no
better feeling even and cross everything
in CrossFit so I do in the open was
class like doing those workouts with
class but following a deadlift record in
competition is the single most linked
but yeah like but could have cried
easily could have cried every time I've
done that's awesome so otherwise on that
again I was watching him a vlog physic
blonde freak from the north of England
o'clock Dillon Nelson Dillon if you
watch him you know love you but watching
his strong watching him get ready for a
lift is the most electric thing I think
I've ever seen in competition yeah and
he was talking on a vlog where he was
saying about how he gets to the point
where he feels like every hair like on
his body is just standing up and you can
see he's one of those guys who is not
chill at alone he's like a bull he's
like someone's just taken you know that
when they're in there when they're doing
corralling or whatever it is in like
Texas and it's just in the thing and
then they lift the Gator goes
[Music]
yeah there's easily competed with him
didn't we like a few he competed when I
watched when we went to go watch you in
Ashington when you men that know there's
an alley salt oh yeah yeah I know that
so there's two other guys that have so
own Hubbard watching him about a bunch
like record-level stuff
he just gets his like I watch them take
iPods out just throw them cuz he's in so
yeah I've watched him throw his iPhone
just off the floor yeah such a such an
like estate so ready to drive hot drive
you just break another yeah Records
bench wreck the thing that blows my mind
about that is to have a a 200 kilo
benchpress and then still year after
year get a better bunch price is
momentum like I feel like the Americans
er listen there'll be more than 50% of
people listening they're American
Congrats to 440 Park
yes yes 440 exactly yeah but that was by
you to 18 or something yeah I use two
ears awareness sir
and I know what was the best thing about
what he just tacked typed Brett Gibbs in
the post I don't really see them I say
is that him Brett Gibbs is a very small
New Zealand guy who is Joe we've met him
he's just as strong as Owen and they
like back and throw back and forth with
it is it amicable oh really
yeah it's amicably okay yeah but like
most people would be like I'm so humbled
and grateful and they just look like
where you are bro maybe another shout
out Reggie fashion who is a crossbow
athlete from Sunderland who competed at
filthy 150 an island via the week and
came one place both Dan Bailey well and
before he before he started this really
like it went round famous it went round
like the CrossFit community in the UK of
Reggie being interviewed and in the same
like so who'd you want to be hit this
weekend oh well that done barely looks a
bit past it doesn't he's like a bag of
[ __ ] spawners now and then sure
enough he plays b1 in one place above
him Sports someone managed to get this
little video clip of both and so Reggie
said this thing he's like called him out
only like two people I hasn't done it
and everyone so let's see how you get on
up against it and then they're walking
off the floor they're in the same heat
together walking off the floor and that
someone managed to catch this video of
the fist bumping and Reggie going like
that and the number of the number of
memes that were made of that was it was
worth it totally worth it
so scopes what's gone what to win apart
from passing when passing medicine
facing me unison yeah that has to be the
wind
otherwise it's been probably the hardest
year of my life just just because of
this such a bottleneck of the total
enormity minotaur yeah like from from
day one because I remember December 2018
I was like things are starting to like
get a little bit out of control and I
fell into 2019 and I still feel like um
I'm like scrub a lot into the start of
the because this because I listened to
it method my homework so what we
discussed a lot was how we started the
year mmm how did everyone start this
year I don't in fact I do like what I
did you you like it what did you well no
one here you supposed I did the propane
goals process sheet and have actually
achieved a lot of that so like oh it's
good to know that that that has moved
forward but the whole time it's felt
just like you know we're controlled
falling yeah not even controlled you you
know you mean you just trip in the
street and then you pretend to go for a
little job but then that job turns into
a sprint and then your arms and if we
media were that guy does on the video
there are you a car very like traffic in
the studies his head yeah on the curve
and he wrote spikes over his head yeah
horrible so what went bad this year then
did you did you have any fails I think
the whole the whole lesson was just not
creating a bit of space between tasks
and rather than just like diving into
everything and just kind of frantically
being behind ridiculous but the plate
spinning it's so it's so two things
first one is I think massive respect
for this year man it's been like
watching it happens been painful like
seeing someone I can't convey to the
listeners just how much stuff you try
and do for trying to do a job which is
essentially more than a full-time
business that a business that would bury
most people whilst trying to do a degree
which buries most students whilst trying
to have like a girlfriend but what to
how like one house managed another house
yes origins did it like yeah I mean well
yeah bought both three houses in kind of
yeah and like all that so I think that's
that's a good point in like we always
hold ourselves to a higher standard but
I look at doctors know that have no
other commitments nothing looks so easy
like what I say to the guys that work
for us at voodoo I'm like in some of the
boys will start to say hey man like my
motivation for work might be waning a
little I mean second year third year you
need Steiner get really serious I'm like
all right man but I'm telling you now
I'm talking tell you what you [ __ ]
here's your [ __ ] Boston I'm telling
you if you just do University University
after having tasted whites like to run a
business whilst doing University you are
going to be bored out of your mind
because you're going to free up all of
this space which sucks in nothing as
opposed to freeing up all of this space
to suck in something well this is like
we were saying last time if we would if
all of us but to do University again
like we'd just absolutely smash it not
because we're anymore
spar or competent or anything but it's
just like you would just know how to use
it to transfer money yeah I did end up
like post finals with a twitch in my
eyelid for about three months to three
months likes just ongoing to itch my
eyelid what does that do you know why
that manifests fatigue like just being
like in a very I gotta I get twitchy me
too I just wonder this menu oh it's
actually the end ethereal and functions
gland in your head
the glands that the head gland the
physical and personable and so I think
the big lesson like both you saw me go
it like hospitalized myself essentially
a couple of years ago from just not
paying attention to fatigue management
well no what was enjoyed that was manage
all the societies but the Giants was
precipitated by being the [ __ ] like
Icelandic welder yeah I'm making us walk
through stop standing in a taxi queue
just which is hilarious okay the only
person out of that group who wore a coat
was you me and Johnny went out in
Iceland on Iceland you were gonna like
25 kilos heavier than me as well at the
Midland Ellie passed away be sure that I
came pretty close to just end a claim
you're actually in heaven now I was
quite honest with you about it I'm not
joking when I say I'm concerned about
this my welfare yeah so the second thing
is um for me I've absolutely been
reminded this year that self-care and
continuing to ensure your well-being is
not a it's not a luxury it's not a
luxury but it's also not like a savings
account it's a current account and you
need to continue to deposit into it
every single day and the times when it's
something that a quote from Paul Moore
is self-care sooner or later becomes
your number one priority which I I just
think is so complete like either sort
your [ __ ] out or you'll have to take
it's like the like I'll do it on Monday
I'll do it on Monday but with your
health it's so weird that health is just
the most like when it's good you don't
even notice it and then yeah that's bad
you all you think about even less so
than the health thing cuz I think all of
us have even even your worst time you'd
have trained once a week probably you'd
have gotten and moved once a week which
is more than some people do we're doing
the gitis but yeah yeah during like busy
oven yeah it's just been on maintenance
luckily it's been 2 to 3 times a week
but like nothing special just background
but it's not just the
what most people would consider like the
headlines like are you having enough
water are you drinking you did what were
you gonna just it's just because the
other day I was looking through our
YouTube channel and I saw one of you
such training logs and deadlifting in a
Jimmy used to train up and it's just the
face
I just went out well I thought of what
I've pictured use of training I just
imagined that face
I think the first podcast we did with
Chris with the coffee and the drugs yeah
but what I love it it's a face that I
don't think you could do now is it no
it's only comes out and alumnus trainer
zoomed in on the yeah squad video
Gardein we'll be able to make that face
appear beep beep it's just here it's the
one when you also try and do like a
double backflip or whatever isn't it in
gymnastics it's the mr. bean face oh
yeah so yeah my point is that um it's
not just about the headlines it's not
just about like sleeping in training
doing that stuff it's like if I wasn't
if I there was period extended periods
where I wasn't meditating extended
periods where I wasn't journaling wasn't
doing the morning routine and it comes
back to bite you in the ass
it's like the first time that all of us
learned that eight hours of sleep is
quite a priority yeah and then when you
go back to six and a half yeah oh my god
yeah this is this is where I used to be
this is what life used to be like and
that's what life's always like well if
there simply were if you were to say
like imagine what it's like when it's
dark mornings and dark nights nearly
getting six hours of sleep but you're
like medicating with loads of caffeine
how do you think you feel that like 1:00
in the afternoon like the thought of
that it's just this like fabricated
environment like this is a variable a
very anxious but yeah it's something up
something one of my takeaways was you
you create the good day of the bad day
so like if you go through today feeling
[ __ ] feeling tired feeling angry or
demotivate whatever like you are just
you're responsible for that and you were
also responsible for the days where you
sleep a productive or
it's just the consistency with things
that like the on-ramp that creates that
situation it's just that it's on loan or
is like there's a delay isn't that yeah
the sleep thing like because
midnight.you is okay it's like ah I'll
be fine in the morning yeah and then
6:00 a.m. you is like oh yeah so yeah I
think that's such a good point like I'm
getting getting a handle much more on
that now and I think through the
bottleneck things that all of us have
swam in and out of the deep the deep
part of this ocean right some of us like
you dudes a period is here where you are
meditating or like you weren't meant to
take consistent you know and you felt
that and then there's the same for me
but the phenomenon that you mentioned
which is like meditation then becomes
not like a thing that's meant to improve
your life and quote it's you're a
[ __ ] if you don't and if you haven't
done ten minutes a day because then you
you're lying the been you getting
flashbacks of like when you were like
eating a pack of crisps or doing
something that that wasn't waste like
maybe seven minutes and then you're like
why am i doing it and so one of the
things definitely that I've focused on
the Sierra that's been a big realization
for me this year is learning where the
controllables and young controllables
are and allowing those uncontrollables
to sort of let go
many is such a liberating feeling so a
good example we do everything right with
a particular club night launch and it
goes really well great
we do everything right with a particular
karate club night launch and it goes bad
like that's a shame but what can we
maybe look at do the effort doesn't
change and the same thing with the
podcast there's some episodes that part
this year that I was like that's on our
episode and it's absolutely flown and
then the Sun that poured my heart and
soul into and thought he was amazing and
it's just like done okay that's
absolutely yeah well there's videos that
flying you're like oh yeah like why is
that I made over five three one review
couple years ago it's very little effort
into it and it's like forty-four
thousand views it gets comments most
days like in Hawaii like so long yeah
yeah yeah just wish you could go back
and remake the video yeah but it's too
late now to tell you like well I'm
messing with alchemy like
if I remaking it doesn't do as well or
but yeah like that was something that um
Brian meditation teacher was said to me
because I was saying like I'll sit down
to meditate in the morning and allocate
30 minutes to it is just [ __ ] shite
session see like well I could have just
done some work in that time what if I
actually gained from that and his thing
was don't judge the session judge your
approach to the session sure like so
like you made the time did you digi you
deal with what was there with the the
right opportunity good if so box ticked
see that that's the beautiful thing
about Shinzon's approach to meditation
for the people who don't know what we're
talking about shins and Jung is a
meditation teacher / master stuff
probably one of the best known on the
planet now I suppose and both me and
Johnny are being coached by one of his
students guy called Brian and the three
elements of awareness clarity
concentration and equanimity the
equanimity thing is so crucial just
allowing States like a - it session
whatever and as he quotes it there are
no bad sits is why he says essentially
there's no wasted meditation there also
no good sit yeah negative yet so that
what else I'm trying to think about
something that's a little bit more
immediate and gratifying the after in
this year what do you mean just things
you've done stopped taking caffeine
within the first 90 minutes of my day
nice and really really got a taste for
pint of water two big squirts of lemon
juice and teaspoon of salt really buying
a pint of water where I've doesn't
smooth I've done like it so I can make
an assister five grams that's a lot of
so my grams so a teaspoon a teaspoon of
salt is a lot of salt that's a lot of
salt so like I've done I used to have so
I raised up I ready to say how much salt
it is alright
your pockets 5 grand
I read the gulp remark is a book yeah I
was like no no ready that's the city
talked about journalist he might but
he's been on he talked about the the
salt water lemon in the morning so as we
all would when a claim is made I was
like what I can't knocked here to grab
this so I did it for a while but I would
I would do it in like that much would
they enjoy the taste I'd say why I
really enjoyed the taste of it now very
people salt or sea salt tables on a
super cheap show she's yep don't what
are you doing every day
well I'll just read yourself do you know
that Himalayan sea pink Himalayan sea
salt isn't even from the inner layers
it's from Pakistan just month and I yeah
anyone's and sea salt beautiful I'll get
me Malden well you know the flakes is in
the Box yeah it's good steak righteous
beautiful yeah so you have it cold water
yes it's from the fridge filtered so
apparently and this is you're getting
another step towards more what planet
Lulu it's warmer water in the morning is
better I'm not doing that okay I prefer
that is that would be ridiculous but
that's how you make yourself sick if you
eat warm salt water isn't interesting
you've had something you should use it
throughout if I put glove woolen glove
even the tip of the finger a woolen
glove in my mouth I feel so what you
like it like it normal like you go pick
a picture a glove yeah about the
experience yeah like Dexter I'm wearing
gloves picking [ __ ] I wanna take the
glove off so I go yeah and then just
immediately and it's like is it the
feeling of you going through the teeth
no it's just there it's just like
mechanical about the experience that we
made me feel so if you value even if you
accidentally deep throating you going
yeah the whole gloves down my neck yeah
no it's it is literally between the tip
of my teeth and I have to if someone
would to see me do it I go like this
your vomit stories
who had the sympathy bomb in the yeah
but you're all throwing up but he walked
past me high up as well yeah that was so
funny but you know need you to wish you
had a moment recorded yeah it was the
way that he just say what try everything
try to see see beyond the second gloves
off this is makeup I like the texture
bits have been dry but you know I'm
gonna guess it'll leave a couple of five
five baths
on you think for me it horrible like
feeling down the back of your head what
you like yeah but to a bit of fall away
from your teeth yeah we saw a fabric any
like I think Cotton's quite badly
bite onto it and then pull it through
your teeth no I don't think so
yeah post Paula Cyrene like you know the
white stuff that like my mum my mum's
got a thing about like finally your
nails
so I'll just feel that sat with her and
she'll start filing your nails yeah
unhelpful thing yeah what else from this
year so I'm just thinking about about
sort of what scum well this year so I
successful project yeah and what wisdom
is absolutely flown it allows the
us-pakistan crook you broke the it was a
two million 1.3 mil now so we broke him
1 million downloads which is great
we sat means BMD set a target for plays
in for subs smashed the target for plays
subs is lagging a little but still to
subscribers matter so the reason that it
mattered the reason that I considered it
as a metric to be bothered about was
just that having subs on YouTube allows
you to then further push more content
that is gonna get more of a head start
right but it would appear that the audio
platform this years absolutely banged so
again so the audio / video yeah I mean
yeah we've got some really big shout
outs on audio like or break shout it out
the audio version
the podcast Jordan Peterson shout out
that Michaela on Jordans podcast shouted
out the the iTunes said that really
drove a lot of traffic which was great
but the the Egypt's are still flying man
so we'll do some special stuff him in
ego which should be excited about this
time last year we were doing the first
modern with some life may be a bit Elias
okay everywhere when we did it for you
Nikolai big radio station alright too
much it'll be listening to any listen
okay
and yeah and then we told a roomful of
people that whose income relies on radio
that radios dead yeah sorry I wonder
whether they've started a podcast I was
worried about the cost wasn't it blossom
I mean you know for a national radio
show with lots of funding obviously that
the hosting fee is a real concern you
know well there's this owners yeah
that's right I'll be like 25 quid very
bloody serious like that pounded
everything every day why be trouble to
this year that we call tier where you've
gone so I spent my so this was the other
thing I'm thinking about this is the
last one of these I'll do in my twenties
to so I spent my 29th birthday in
auschwitz-birkenau [ __ ] you did yeah
very morbid yeah but brilliant kills
[ __ ] Krakow is brilliant outfits and I
mean obviously it feels wrong saying
that brilliant but it's a hell of an
experience so as the salt mines in
Krakow sorry to Krakow I went to
Santorini you take it you won you wait
you didn't line to get [ __ ] if you're
invited Ramona yeah hashtag blessed all
right yes life I'm so [ __ ] sick of
that [ __ ] the instability in yeah like
I'm quite pleased that Instagram and it
are like moving in the direction where
it feels like they've kind of clocked it
and they're making some changes let's
discussing this with someone near the
day the fact that likes are now no
longer being shown it's just single
person and others like this post right
is
it's getting rolled out quite heavily
across the UK now I think if someone has
something to share like something that's
interesting or funny or valuable they
find but like when it's just photos of
people in Santorini and they'll and the
photo gets loads of traction because
it's like a certain angle right
did we talk about this last time with
like people that will order a meal for
two in the restaurant and then take a
photo at the table and leave and not eat
really not even me okay this was up it
so in Thailand like Lou and we were in
this pool top of it
outing like a secluded place nice hotel
outside outdoor pool with you know where
the edge just drops off to me and
infinity pool yeah and like a forest
behind it you see temples in the
background and me and my girlfriend were
just enjoying the pool like just having
a swim and stuff me drinking a coconut
with a thing and and we we saw a couple
after couple come into the pool
boyfriend fully dressed but with like a
big DSLR thing and girlfriend like
they'd be full makeup hair done heels
like what looks like a really expensive
swimsuit with leather like shoulder pads
and her and they've come over and sit on
the side of the pool then like and by
pose and stuff like and do like an
hour's photoshoot and then leave anybody
like are you guys gonna get into the
pool or enjoy it around it
and it happens so consistently on the
south coast of sorry on the west coast
of gili t sunset one of the most
beautiful picturesque islands on the
planet probably just outside of Bali and
there is you'll have seen those swings
those sunset swings there in the middle
of the ocean like in people sit on them
and usually got like it's like a kind of
rustic wooden swing type thing anyway
Sun there and uh I'm watching hashtag
boyfriend's of Instagram get down is
this Chinese guy who's there who's
taking photos for his girlfriend you
want a good photo and what she wants is
as much reflection off the water as is
possible
so what he's had to do is get down he's
lowering himself down further and
further and the waters this high but the
phone needs to be up but he can be lower
so every so often he's taking this wave
in the face
like as he's trying to get this phone I
was just thinking the sacrifices that he
makes and it was that everyone was
trying to out extra everyone else I mean
this is coming from the guy who did like
a legless rope climb to get to the top
of it so that I was like at the very
very top that was my photo but then a
guy everyone was taking photos everyone
was looking cool and a local guy just
rode past on a horse took the horse out
into the middle of the water and stood
on the horse mixed everyone I was just
think you might what a way to [ __ ] on
everyone's my race because you like you
think you think that you're on the swing
I got a whole eyes class well I I went
up to a couple of a few of the couples
like when we were out cuz they bring the
boyfriend taking photos of the girls
stuff and I would go over and be like
you want me to get a shot of you both
and there was blond it's okay it's like
okay obviously you don't want a you've
shines a light on the weird situation
you know I'm just having a photo to
comments like the email went to this
place together no just for the graph use
one individual photos so what did you go
this yet so Budapest on I think on
Johnny's recommendation or like went to
the place thinking about just to mention
I spoke to someone this week you said to
me that they got dog because I settlers
Susie we should be careful
Budapest area put a bus its average I
thought it was alright it's this like
standard-issue European city has it got
direct flights from the UK
yeah that's why this any as soon as
anyone gets direct flights from the UK
to [ __ ] really the stuff that it's
just stacked is it's just immediately as
soon as you can go to anywhere if you
need to do a connecting flight my glance
Ehrenreich wid stock dude yeah I mean
Budapest wasn't very staggie it was
quite cultural you're a bit like the one
thing I did find and this is like it's
the equivalent of Iceland everything is
nine and a half thousand pounds is that
everything in Budapest is 10 minute walk
away on Google Maps but feels like 40
minute walk
brilliant any distance between any two
points in the city is like as a miracle
is ten minute walk
but it's really far prostate under yeah
so that that's quite good similar
consoling experience going to the Jewish
Museum yeah in the synagogue where you
just see mass graves and things to go to
the baths yeah you get you dick only
great baths
it wasn't a naked one just uh but did
you get you to go just in general at
some point during the holiday oh I had
to yeah it's a service twice a day at
least twice a day at least twice a day
yeah always indoors always legal legal
situation like all the bats were awful
did you get together I will have done
yet with the baths not in the bus not
not where other people did you just go
to one bath yeah I wonder if you write
some better than others definitely but
you know you know when you're getting
changed in a swimming pool and there's
the the sort of the cold stagnant water
in the center you so clearly turns up
trying to step in the baths the whole
bath just felt like yeah that's positive
it just a bit like any spot the bag a
large parts of a smaller bag like
Iceland hmm so Buddha persimmon just
came back from Barcelona which is
beautiful did he go to the Sagrada
família yeah stepping on them
Gaudi is a monster like he so for anyone
that doesn't know he's the architect and
artist designer of a lot of buildings
around Barcelona and it seems like he's
designed so many of them and each one is
so intricate looks like at least like a
decade of work you're just thinking how
is he pumped out so much output and then
all the designs are very fluid and
asymmetrical and kind of flowing looking
buildings that just looks so out of out
of context with anything else he's done
the major Cathedral which is bigger than
you think on from the pictures you'd
imagine him like giving the plan to the
builders and they're just like our gaudi
man yeah [ __ ] you Tommy couldn't have
just been a bit two by fours good it how
am I supposed to make this Rob Rob we're
gonna have to Rob's like it know
everything everything's gonna have to be
knocked on the head he's brought the
peace brought the plans yes I don't man
you're not gonna you're not gonna
believe this
do not I repeat do not ring me
[ __ ] sick of you know I'd make you
believe you rank me what I said not to
yeah so Barcelona it's not mugging there
isn't it yeah so that a lot of
pickpockets mugging so actually it's
transitioned used to be very
pickpocketing and now it's gone - okay
it used to be very much like if you have
your phone on a table in a restaurant
someone would come along with a
newspaper mark yeah I'm looking for this
okay nevermind thank you or like um
stuff like that now it's just going to
fill up just like mode and like so a
friend of mine who I went to visit got
beaten up so she got like a black eye
and she bruised head for like a rubbish
phone and so it's just become flavored
now it's interesting that so we got
murdered on the street who was staying
on tonight we were that what the [ __ ]
Jesus Christ it was a murder on the
night that we while you were there yeah
where you were yeah as you get on the
street it wasn't even you I was in the
murder I didn't know I didn't do the
murder always the murder probably so but
it didn't make news because it was it
was a gang thing I don't like they were
are well it probably worked first person
on the list is the Arab that was staying
just around the corner yeah I don't want
to do that that doesn't because they
don't want to get there ah that the best
the best thing was in the airport they
kept releasing this announcement it was
like well Mohammed Abu Jaya please go to
security immediately so I went to
Barcelona for a wedding this the start
of this summer and one of the guys that
through there doesn't usually drink had
a little bit too much to drink at the
wedding then walking through the center
of Barcelona after we being up to this
beautiful castle had this wonderful day
got the bus back that bus dropped us off
and he just went over wonder who's
staying in a B&B
he woke up a few hours later 7:00 in the
morning
with in Barcelona train station actually
to find the
his phone wallet and shoes have been
sold as had taken his shoes and then so
he then walked around for the next few
hours in his brand-new pair of Ralph
Lauren socks just walking around and
he's a baby guy wearing like a kind of
dish it was like obviously disheveled
wedding suit which is just in Barcelona
which has got a lot of homeless just the
quintessential homeless man look like
long beard really odd outfit like with
suit full suit and tie no shoes like
Ralph Lauren socks now with holes into
people like him a couple of coins or
something but it was desperately trying
to say can I borrow your phone but in
the mugging the mugging and robbery
capital of Europe like that was never
gonna happen and then because he wasn't
staying in a hotel he didn't know he
couldn't ask where the hotel was because
he didn't know the address of the air
B&B off by heart so he's just walking
around Barcelona with none of his
possessions as hangover and sort of
existential crisis slowly begins to see
if he's really goosed in there and how
hopeless we are when we don't have it's
literally what he says oh yeah it's this
Oracle that connects us to everything
else
I always feel whenever I go somewhere if
I have my wallet in my phone I can just
deal with anything like anything that
happened you can buy your way out of it
you're depending on the currency or well
you've been robbed if this was the first
holiday I've done with a new phone and
therefore I don't have a little book
book mm-hmm so I decided not to bring
any cards no cash just everything was
Apple pay and it felt lovely to just tap
around it's a bit it feels a bit like if
it goes wrong is you're really [ __ ]
money
what doesn't you just gotta know mate
means a payment you've hinged all of
your risk on that I've had that I've had
scenarios where I've gone to use Apple
pay and it's not
well yeah interesting and then there's
police come after you
yeah yeah you've had a run-in with a
spammer you've both had run-ins with
Spanish police I hope you hmm I feel
like mine wasn't my fault it was your
lawyer friend who yeah but I feel like
you mind if I was you I felt I was
asleep on the central reservation of ten
reefs largest melt away yeah yeah I
don't never fun I didn't accidently well
that wasn't it you didn't mean to it was
just a bad day it was but it was very
very badly
so I've done it this is probably the
year of done the single most amount of
traveling Wow I've ever done so I did
America so all right I'll try I'll try
and go through it so did Rome for my
birthday which was one of the best I've
ever done like just so amazing three or
four days in Rome and just overwhelmed
with colosseum & roman forum day one
Vatican and Sistine Chapel day two and
Pompeii day three but what a ways and
just an espresso or something I've got
this story and so the first the first
thing I did I was looking like just
totally befuddled by the romance that is
Rome looking out of the window as I put
sugar into my espresso and was just
stirring it and looking at like just how
beautiful everything was starin its toe
and it's thrown it and looked back to
see there was no espresso left in the
cup barely any espresso on the saucer
and the glass counter upon which it was
resting where all of the pastries and
super behind it it just made itself of
that and the owner was just looking at
me like this I was like could have
another espresso please like those all I
could think but then while I did that in
the time it took me to stir that and
have all of it come out a man came in
bought a glass of red wine finished it
and went back to work that's that
Italy's brilliant so yeah
Rome they're just drinking such a paste
waiter than they I don't believe the
first thing you said was carve another
espresso I think I probably said like
sorry viola said like you know it was
his face what you mean to me you can
come in and stop throwing it around so
Samia feces on the attack
anyway so Rome great la and Boston saw
David dr. David Sinclair awesome then
went back and went family or muscat he
lives oh yeah
read some of the airway Elon Musk
breathed went to New York for a Stein to
force them what to be there for another
stag dude that was good
went to Barcelona for that wedding then
did road trip across America to 2,000
miles in ten days that was cool more raw
more didn't do wrong what that time did
Rama didn't Feb read into Rome and then
he may go streaming l Canada for the
first time and then went to Bali
most recent stayed with Stu McGill's
yeah of all the things you've done that
was pretty crazy
went on his yacht one day it was about
it can still be a yacht yeah like yachts
don't have to be big but yeah I think
you know in trying to create some sort
of a sense of what people that are
listening who maybe aren't doing any
formal gratitude or aren't doing end of
your reviews I think what we're trying
to do here is just take stock of what's
happened within the last year you know
that what's gone well what's gone bad if
you're not careful life does just be
this treadmill of task arises you get
the malla out you whack it it goes away
next task arises mallet whack and you
just keep on going and then before you
know it yeah you just ruthlessly indexed
these experiences and never actually
enjoyed reflecting it's like just
endlessly painting but then never
stepping back to look at the painting
isn't it like you spend all your life
trying to achieve things and you just
die but if you just if you've never like
go ah [ __ ] the thing that I spent he's
trying to achieve I did that I'm not
cool hmm right next thing and rather
just next thing next thing oh my god
yeah bollocks have you um have you had
any mind shifts or any sort of lessons
this year or any concepts that you've
learned that have been a big sort of
frame shift for you
if you don't I've got my 1 which i think
is probably one of my biggest room this
year so I've written down five here
while they're quick some of them are
completely irrelevant you can you you
create good days and bad days if it
doesn't happen first thing it very
rarely happens so that applies to like
the days you wake up and you're like I
really should meditate
wait that's not I opened my phone to try
and look at some myself and the first
thing that came up was a VTO bum hole
sent from Chris eat spinach is
everything you've learned the more in
the morning when the Dave must yeah so
like that applies to you things like so
I'm back to training in the morning
because I've realized that like when I
tell myself ah it's alright I'll train
the 6 p.m. promise
she never do unless there's a massive
accountability that's a great thing
about CrossFit instantly all work so
like just do the thing that has to be
done today
just do that first get it done yeah this
is a marketing thing sales is a process
not an event people think that it's an
event or like a thing that they did have
did think they've done that caused a
sale it's what happened prior to that
the cause the sale who not how to solve
a problem so this year I've invested
myself not under the propane umbrella
because those numbers are making more ii
put in the club in your mouth the most
money personally in coaching so i've
worked with the most coaches in might
for my own stuff so like if you're
trying to get better or something or
trying to achieve stuff just which is
the next thing model consistent examples
of where you want to be so not someone
who's like where you were wanting to be
and there's been there for a bit but
someone who's like consistently doing
the thing that you were trying to get to
you just pay them to learn how so always
asking instead of just grinding away and
like what book can i read what course
can I do how can I figure this out
myself just who's doing it and I'll just
work with them life is short
just just get the answers yeah I think
that's that's such a [ __ ] good
heuristic and I was one
to me kind last year I think all I still
haven't fully implemented it um being
able to shortcut all of the self
directions self-accountability
questioning is this the right should I
do act why's that it's like just just
ask the person yeah like if you want to
know the best way to fix you back drive
to counter so you feel girl yeah like so
many people Mike I think we've all been
guilt in this like you spent so long
trying to figure something out yourself
like in your own whatever it is and you
might not even be necessarily not aware
of it but like people read books and
things that do courses on things rather
than just paying a bit more and getting
someone who's really experienced in that
area to give you some customers help on
that thing so with men I tried with
meditation for years to figure it out
myself and just chatting to someone who
I don't know there's no like
qualification or level of expertise
necessarily even it just pay for some
formal how yeah and I think there's two
things that for me of obstruct this here
there's a lesson I'll go into a second
but two of the big things is what I'm
missing most and what many people that
are in this kind of knowledge work
self-directed world of personal
development might be struggling with the
two things I think are most important a
direction and accountability it's like
if you know what you need to do and you
have someone he'll tell you often if you
don't do it and encourage you if you do
9 percent of the works done for you what
do I need to do and why do I need to do
it essentially all yes that what's the
pain silent on the reason yeah yeah it's
a great point unless the value of a
coach isn't it rather than just the
information I think most people if
they're just given the information they
won't execute unless there is
accountability objectivity and
personalization yeah and so although
this huge untapped potential of just
getting a book on something like as Tim
Ferriss says like most of the time if
you want to become a relative expert in
this in a certain field compared to
everyone else you just read a book on it
or read like two or three books on it
and suddenly you know more than
ninety-nine point
yeah and that is usually very helpful
but if he was trying to solve a specific
problem it may be more useful quicker to
get a coach to diagnose identify your
specific issues even if at the end of
the day they just recommend you a book
it'll be a book that is relevant to your
problem well the problem is no longer
lack of information the problem today is
which information which information
should you listen to and should you not
listen to is this disgusting amount of
it for me yeah
one of Oliver's synopsis on the Joe
Rogan podcast was all of the problems
that we have now our problems of
abundance not scarcity yeah everything
because it's very much food too much
stimulus it's heartbreaking to think
like you have this thing you definitely
trying to do and you spend a year just
following the wrong advice the wrong
advices can you please get use it
Ireland's fortune I get was right all
along
like on the day of the competition I'll
give him the wrong advices has everyone
seen that quote yeah um so I want to do
I'll do your lesson of the urn of mine
and then I want to do like top three
books each top three podcasts each top
three YouTube videos each just whatever
whatever does come to mind so I'll give
you as a little bit of time to have a
think but honey your any lesson from
this year and he sort of frameshift of a
new concept that you've brought in I
think you like it's all very similar
like the the coaching thing I've also
just spent a lot on just investing in
myself but I think also just taking time
to period eyes the things that you want
to improve in your life and take space
between each one so trying to achieve
everything all at once so I heard
something today it was from C muffins
actually where he says sin refers to
some neuroscience research I feel like
he may have been kind of approximating
so but basically said like when you have
gold a blue and action a you sit and you
do call a with action a until you
achieve it when you have goal a and gold
B and you have action a in action B your
brain dedicates more resource to the
switching between the tasks then it does
to following either of those two
and we're just not very good at trying
to do two things at once whether that's
on a micro or a micro scale so we know
on a micro scale like it's why we're all
such a big fan of Pomodoro's and they're
like this it's the most it's the best
way to just say like okay I'm just going
to do this one thing to the exclusion of
everything else rather than like feel
the background guilt about our but I'm
not doing that other thing so I'm going
to just do a little bit other one while
I'm and like I still always fall into
the trap of not doing that but so
there's there's that and then were a
larger scale over the year I think like
imagine if 20 20 20 was 12 new habits
rub done each month rather than starve
day 1 20 22 trying to eat all twelve
habits at once rather than nailing habit
one for January and then running it in
the background blast and cruise I think
the thing attached to that is when you
don't so the problem I I have with doing
like a yearly review is remembering all
the things that have happened like
there'll be stuff that I've done and
achieved that I don't even didn't even
really mention like what I was going to
say before was I didn't even painting
the wall painting the picture yeah yeah
I did three months of not drinking at
the start of the year come on the link
you've got completely forgotten about it
massive achievement so I know the twelve
habits thing just keep a record of it
somewhere yeah cuz that line out at the
start of the year yeah especially people
with like our view are you always
pushing it achieve things aren't you so
if you just forget that you've done them
what was the point in doing them yeah
yeah I think so for next year one of the
things I've jumped ahead but next year
one of the things I'm going to have to
learn to do is to say no to a lot more
I've spread myself too thin this year
and having spent a little bit time with
Chris sparks that did that podcast with
her mind the forcing function top twenty
online poker players on the planet and
absolutely [ __ ] of a
productivity expert
um I'm spread so thin I'm never going to
become amazing at any one thing and then
last is some sort of synergistic
relationship between much of the stuff
I'm doing which there isn't sufficiently
to warrant it I need to make a decision
on what it is that I want to do what did
it what what is it that I want to do so
2020 for me I think will be the year of
saying no to a lot more saying yes to a
lot more stuff that I need to like
social engagements which will be enabled
by saying no to more work engagements
and stuff like that I think one of the
big concepts that I've learned this year
which I really really appreciate was
Laura van becomes time management thing
which is talking about how memories are
made
and I think this is so fundamental and
fundamentals that everybody everyone
should be taught it everyone should know
it that everyone's experience of the
passage of time happens at precisely the
same speed even if you're traveling at
close to the speed of light your
experience of the passage of time is
exactly the same as mine now or if
you're a child or if you're eight years
old or whatever it is the passage of
time is one of the constants that's not
going to change for you so when people
say I wish I had more time because they
complain that the years where's the year
gone you know it's nearly 2021 man can
you believe it like he feels like it was
only Christmas yesterday and the reason
that that happens has got nothing to do
with the passage of time and everything
to do with your memory of the passage of
time so if you think about the way you
have the the future self which is the
person you'll anticipate about what's
going to go on you have the remembering
self which is the person that remembers
what's happened and you have the present
self which is the experiencer the person
that's experiencing the thing right now
the experiencing self is the most
fleeting of those the anticipating self
tends to be the next the longest because
you only know it was so far into the
future and the remembering self is
essentially infinite so what people say
I wish I had more time what they mean is
I wish I had more memories because
memories are like little lines little
individual blocks that allow you to ex
and out that experienced the passage of
time so to the people who are listening
if you think about the route that you
take to work out your drive to work ask
you to remember your drive to work this
year it's condensed down perhaps several
hundred hours of travel into one memory
use single memory of you doing that or
your drive to the gym unless there was
one time where something specifically
different happened car crash a
particular phone call like you were
elated for some reason your brain just
condenses it down and the rule to use is
that your brain works well with novelty
or intensity those are two of the things
that you can do to ensure that your
memories are increased and that's why I
can't remember barely any of my drives
to the work or to work or the gym this
year but I can remember the name of the
guy who put us on the boat in Africa
over a year and a half ago and I can
remember the book that he was reading
and I can remember the shoes that he had
on because it was both novelty and
intensity in that so if you want to make
time in the passage of your life feel
like it is moving more slowly then you
need to first off try and vary what you
are doing you need to allow yourself to
become invested emotionally to actually
indulge yourself in the present moment
and then once it's happened you need to
remember it you need to think about it
so bizarre thing is when you're
experiencing the experiencing self such
a prick like Nonie did they take the
easiest route so they'll say ah don't go
and do that that adventurous thing
because it's cold and a beds warm and
I'm tired and I'm this and I'm that and
the other which totally [ __ ] over the
remembering self and the anticipating
self because they want it to happen
the presents are [ __ ] like folks it
the other thing as well is the present
self always picks out the discomfort
it's such an [ __ ] so let's say that
I'm watching this beautiful sunset on
gili t I've got a little bit sand
between my toes and it's slightly
irritating and it just takes the edge
off but when I remember I don't remember
the Sun between my toes but I do
remember the beauty so it's like you try
to need to kind of almost use your
experiences as an investment for
yourself in the future so I look I'm
going to do this thing because in the
future and I think about me doing it I'm
going to enjoy it and I'm gonna be proud
of it I'm gonna do this and that
friendship for me this year has been but
a real big one so seek
and intense experiences yep absolutely
without taking the piss so like don't
like drive to the gym dresses mr. blobby
here well don't take it either another
there's certain the certain happiness
you could say that if you stick your
EpiPen indeed for the river it was that
is that a problem where they find it
that with that would have to be the
hospital
thank you but if talk you pulled out 317
deadlift you're a fan so you have to go
to home the day of the competition can
use about the day before can't use that
befell find the day before but I'm not
sure we help ya a before but I don't
know if you if you just took it yep
probably yeah but just to be safe I mean
it's not a reaction you have to go to
hospital because the EpiPen wears off
and then yeah yeah I just mean now just
for fun yeah the I have anything what if
you had that peanut well I don't that's
the thing fair enough that's the lesson
um yeah there's the final point on that
is there is no trade-off that you need
to make between efficiency and novelty
so for instance one of the things that
Gretchen Rubin suggests to increase
novelty is to every soft and walk a
different route to work or drive a
different route to work but there's only
so far you can take that I don't get
drive out to the coast to go Jesmond
like so you know there are there's
trade-off that you need to make how does
the sea efficient government or after
you as well to take different routes
yeah and then if you do this when you
walk across the cameras yeah because
it's because it's her on this greatly
modified if you do that when you want to
buy bleach yes 12 pots of legally right
it's my father come up with you top few
anything's that you've either read
article podcast look youtube video
anything come to mind you know what I
struggle with this is getting it in the
year okay if it's if it's anything that
just comes to mind because it can't be
next year because it hasn't happened
last true it cannot be in the future but
that's the one thing with me sure so
video
Anton creoles five principles behind the
ten rules for financial success that
I've watched that for the third
run this year new things come out of a
each time lesson something from both of
you actually kind of merged which was
Johnny's suggestion I think that the end
of last year's review was have more
dinners with friends and yours have just
check in with friends I think I've
realized this year when I've been in a
mad whirl wind that you end up taking
friends and family for granted or not
checking in with them or not being in
touch with them and I was kind of
working up by this just yesterday
because my mum's going past the hospital
popped in came back to see her for a cup
of tea and she was tearful that I didn't
send her a picture of my trip to
Barcelona and I realized like how much
that matters to her because she's got a
picture from like my girlfriend's mom
and you know and I think just like oh
[ __ ] yeah damn it yeah because and that
was a real like art man I really need to
just like that obviously that must have
a lot more to her and thinking those
those terms a bit more so yeah that's
good
Jenny you've just been scrolling where
we go so I looked through my audiobooks
confinement Oh terrible books this yeah
are some average ones
so my I've got I have a novel give me
the Avicii documentary alright yeah yeah
the reason for that is so I don't think
you don't like me to do these acquires
OHS so I really like his music with it
Samsung have just put on YouTube a like
a trivia concert in 4k and live
brilliant like tea I was not brilliant
at anyway so the documentary is like
lead also they publicly say didn't
commit suicide but the concert is
donated to mental health awareness so
mmm-hmm I think it was an overdose
I think it's a drugs overdose was it
like accidentally Iraqi meant to kill
him Sir
no I've read some unity
so there's risk of the one
but anyway they claimed to say it's not
suicide if you did that there's only
like really very statement vice family
well anyway the documentary is about him
and him managing his mental success so
like he has what probably any
mid-twenties guy it is in some way
aspiring to in like abundance across the
board over the stuff that he has and in
the documentary he's pretty intensely
unhappy about it what my problems are I
think it all just is a bit too much for
him like he gets pancreatitis from
drinking it doesn't like the the the
performing because it's too stressful
and there's too much going on too many
things to manage the pressure from the
fans and all sort of stuff and he's a
perfectionist with the music so it's
just this I watched it and I was like
really moved by watching it because if
you think about the things that you're
doing most of the time it's the pursuit
of one of the things that he has in
excess and he's there and hated it
because and it's the self-care thing
like it's a self-care thing and also
realizing that like probably all he
wants is to be someone who isn't him
like well he wants us to be someone who
is desiring to be there so just an
interesting like perspective really sad
because like because he's like a similar
age he's a bit introverted
it was just what take you in the fields
I don't know it isn't doesn't say Hodge
really want I think for some of it it
seems like he wants to be like left
alone and wrong yeah and like he's there
because he's really good at a craft and
then isn't it bizarre that you can have
someone who is perhaps like super
overqualified in terms of talent to be
able to get themselves to it particular
place but doesn't have the character to
keep themselves there there was a
documentary about the ages ago like some
genetically is like either genetically
engineered all I can jointly selected
world's smartest boy okay and he was
born with they were born to be selected
for
highest IQ and they were interviewing
him and he was like I'm not really
interested in doing and me I just wanted
to have a nice life and like and come on
like you should like memory competition
yeah and he's like yeah podcasts Joni
any podcasts come to mind other than of
course program fitness how to start your
online business and model is that was a
really good one the hard being online
coach burning no I mean is drawing
allowed me to drop in Navarre rabbika
and Joe Rogan very good [ __ ] is he had
to appearance it's just one he said he's
not doing any guest appearances for the
foreseeable future mouth if you haven't
listened to it it might not be up your
street but if you want the two and a bit
hours of probably the densest wisdom
that you're going to get from someone
Navarre Roth account and Joe Rogan was
great Sam Harris I'm Joe Rogan at the
start of the year was also fantastic
trying to think about what I've gone
back and listened to so you know all
this is making me think is I need to to
keep a log of this stuff like any of
things that happen that are great and
little things that I watch or listen to
or whatever that are great three three
great things that happened to me today
bottom of the sixth I'm you learn a
condensed like that I could just scroll
through now is day one the art I do but
not for this yeah for like momentous
thing is amounting mind serious because
it's password-protected
I don't autonomy I don't need a password
protect my podcast recommendation but
that yet that was good I can't remember
much of the chasing excellence it's a
good book chasing accent receipt your
minimalism was this year meant anomic
habits book of the year that was last
year I might get this year right
[Music]
digit minimalism I wasn't so I wasn't so
I think it's a great it's an important
message because none of us did it like
we but really all read it mustn't Harlan
and how when he writes just comes across
a tiny bit whiny do you not think it's
just a little he's such a contrarian
when it comes to it's a perfect world of
you should just be able to do
and I'm aware that there are
contingencies in some of the things that
you put across but there's just it feels
to me like there's not enough of a
realistic understanding of how
challenging this is going to be so that
yeah so like it's a it's an important
message and some good concept but I
think the unfortunate truth of it is
like a lot of us are so hard wired
emotionally to these things that just
going all right I'll just drop it now
that anymore it's very hard to do I know
one guy who did and it's took yeah can't
hit me by David Goggins really struggle
with that did you listen or he read so
I'm halfway through it's 13 hours long
so my mom cuts in between it right yeah
so it's like yeah and you got the book
as well you've got the book I know it's
jerk like Dave Cochran says it's
obviously a monster but just the the
message is a bit repetitive which is
what is it one of those books that's one
thing that doesn't need to be a book and
they've just like you know yeah I think
you need like exposure to the idea
because the idea is like testing limits
of you of like what you think your limit
is and also a self the best thing
actually which is like two minutes long
is it video by chakra willings channel
if you go on his channel
good good that's brilliant good time
watching the right video skill of like
Navy SEALs you can't argument penny true
because I'll [ __ ] you up good in his
book Joker extreme ownership again half
similar thing okay
alchemy by Rory Sutherland came out this
year that was a good fairly good writers
he read it
yeah cause Hans that's it I'm Simon I
mean yeah this was last year but the
order of time by Carlo Rovelli that was
fairly good waking up by some Harris I
must have listened to it to another two
times this year which was great the
great mental models by Shane parish that
was fantastic
mindfulness in plain English that was
your session that's a really good book
[Music]
all right accidentally pressed on
superintelligence
[ __ ] million million million million
years I think that that's probably my
I've got bags and bags of credits left
inaudible cuz if just not I listen to
the power of now again by Eckhart Tolle
it's very good [ __ ] man yeah the head of
his time wasn't really out of its time
yes super super [ __ ] like he's just
cutting li clear with his message and
he's legit as well like I feel like if
he was in this room not with all the
asleep yeah yeah he is very legit anyway
final thoughts anything that you want to
get across to the humans of the
interwebs before we round off this year
in this Christmas you know what I would
like to know what everyone's plans are
for 2020 what do you mean by plans for
services what for the people watching
what are their wins fails and goals for
win the common seed in 2020 yep there we
go so on YouTube put below what your
best win was what your biggest fail was
and one girl do you want to achieve for
next year really really cool is good
question to consider is in December 2020
what would have to have happened for you
to have been content with a year rather
than thinking like what my goals just
think what would be a nice scenario for
me like when I look back I don't know
don't know you can smile question fyz
them biggest hot potato
that's the ease of the round off a year
with a large unfinished like saying but
a bit cheese a little bit of tuna beans
as well hot bean sauce going on
everywhere like just a nut garden and a
sausage for this would make better at
everything good heuristic obviously good
good good answer would good answer um
final thing to round the euro is I
posted a video on LinkedIn trailer and
of all of the things someone could have
commented with you know this work that
we've put in and we've tried to upload
this this beautiful explanatory video
someone just commented and said is that
the guy
pointless lessons a great something so I
did a I did a sales call with a guy
who's just joining one of our programs
and he got off the sales call with me
sign up to the program I then I've this
first coaching call the next day and he
was like me the weirdest thing I we had
the call and I was like satin evening
thinking about it I turned on the TV and
I was like and he was like I nearly
didn't sign up because your answers are
so [ __ ] I thought I'll lay him off [ __ ]
imagine that if you'd lost a big big
name client because because of because
of my pointless answers from an episode
recorded two years ago it's weird that
the first time it was aired which was
like last year there was a single person
gamers sure how it's caused a ripple
yeah I think issues of isn't this
podcast is it seasonal was it played in
December last time are people watching
more TV now there was a lot of questions
and you know is the price of oil changed
between nothing like what was he mom's
favorite color when did you go next
about a year ago in November last year
okay Wow it was about the same time when
point the field is last time from and I
think dog life is just I'm just seeing
that the Prophet repaid massively for
you like it well like it's there's a lot
of plot on yeah probably the most
intense period of admin in my year admin
admin was when I took date tech tax of
hammers bollocks chopped off the like
firstly I felt horrendous about if are
really bad and guilty about it which II
like I never thought would happen but I
guess we're going in the vets there was
like I was i holding him like
you know and then he like ripped his
stitches out too like taking us back
with in the morning you know you like
you do morning routine you come
downstairs they're ready for like this
the most important acidotic
your are leading us Croton yeah I I
Rich's know how that ring the vets
coming back with now in a problem laptop
shut right Dana Scott there and that was
my eyes fine that will be 40 pound
brother of course so like that but apart
from that massive Barney one sure she's
got a dog cannot wait to get a little
head yeah a little heavy
yeah not get a whip it with psychomotor
retardation a collie greyhound
so in indexes puppy class there was a
greyhound it was this big sure you're
not tiny thing that like it's it's
they're operating on double speed on me
yes as it was a Joe DeFranco warm-up
where he's gets you to do hip circles
that's how is Italian Greyhound called
Jimmy ran so it's like this and it was
like going up like head to head against
his like quite a big cockapoo and I just
looked at it and thought that's great
for you sir like if you could hold it
you'd sit in your hand
but it's a great house it's got all the
features that you want but it's very
manageable sure yeah yeah yeah come up
wait I pick it up and move it it was a
great common sight I've got it properly
like if someone has actually this is
week I'm gonna finish it on this know if
someone has a very docile dog that we
can have for a modern wisdom episode I
would quite like to just have one here
that would be great you're not just like
Mary Lou super chill because it's an
hour of Whitehall is yeah quite I'll
just put like a golden retriever golden
retriever would be nice do they do
poster like if they got this digestion
just put their son daughters you like
proper heavy going tough person
you just don't squeeze it if you squeeze
it like this like a bagpipe then it and
on that note Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas thank you to everyone for
tuning in this year I really do
appreciate the support get in touch
actress Y likes wherever you follow us
or our opening Fitness give them that's
my fault
give them some Christmas on this phone
did you I did sir I'll what await when
the yeah anyway Merry Christmas
[Music]